[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
we talk about whatever we want
do you guys like saying that whatever
it's a staple yeah you know what
happened what i realized
is um when we first started this segment
i i was just like oh my gosh this is
weird we don't have a title
there's no like the guest isn't saying
anything yeah and then also it was like
a description for the fans so they could
know that this is a different type of
video so then that's when i just said
that and then it just stuck forever and
then it just turned into this thing and
i'm like
that's beautiful it's a part of it you
need it that's a little bit of tiff
sprinkled in every episode
even when you're not here to me it's
like it's like chili's baby back ribs
barbecue
but you have sauce you have to do it you
have to living spaces
dude that's like my favorite place why
did those tunes
why was exactly the true angle jingle
sound
get in the zone
but yeah cause then i also like hearing
everyone else's version of
like my intro cause then with casey what
do you say
uh welcome back to the off the record
where we talk about whatever we want
i just imitated i mean he basically
tries to do like what you do but worse
i'm the carbon coffee i'm the carbon
copy no
it's funny because every time casey does
it he's like oh i don't know how this
does it
true now he had cases the first the
first couple of days where i was hosting
yeah i could not get it down
yeah i mean i think you did great it's
your own interpretation yeah
yeah just you know with a lot of
stutters you know i know i know when
that when we had like an
all crew day and ryan was the one that
was hosting he always liked to say like
oh uh we're this is off the record where
we talk about whatever the [ __ ] we want
yeah
cute mine was very aggressive yeah i
just needed to be a little bit different
than the gentle whatever we want
yeah everyone can sprinkle their own
flavor on it that's what i'm saying like
it's so
cute and to me to like see everyone else
do that because the first time you did
it and i was in this room
and then because i started off with like
oh [ __ ]
every time i think about it i always
blank on what i say until
the moment i call action and then it
comes out of my mouth but comes natural
yeah this is honestly like i'm at a
youtube panel at vidcon
questions for us because the person's
always like they're always like yeah
well i came up with uh whatever we want
go ahead everyone claps yep is that what
i'm doing
do you have any questions for the
originator of that phrase when i thought
of it i was in a bathtub and i was like
i just need something that connects with
everybody and like
they just make everything into such a
bigger deal than actually yeah hilarious
i i do remember when it was on the casey
days where he was hosting and he was
trying to intro
like uh off the record and when we
didn't say whatever we want it just
seemed
really off ah it was so off and then i
remember like casey was like no no that
this this doesn't seem right we've got
we gotta do it all over again
yeah that's funny it's like a thing you
do at the beginning just to get into the
mindset
of the episode almost remember my second
vidcon i was there and this guy gets on
stage i had never seen him my entire
life and he gets on stage expecting
everyone to know who the [ __ ] he is
and he's like he's like hey everybody oh
wait wait let me just do that again he's
like
hello world and like nine people clapped
and everything so
he like he's like everyone knows that
i'm supposed to say hello world first
this is that's his catchphrase obnoxious
way
and so that's that's what reminds me of
that no offense to you obviously
i'm actually very offended steve i'm
very you actually compared me to
vidcon panel it reminds me of it but
you're but you're saying is this okay to
even do
it's a completely different thing it's
okay you're like is it okay if we
if i keep saying that you want to change
that oh that's how you started it true i
guess
no no i guess i wanted to know like how
you guys feel saying it
and then i started thinking about the
evolvement of it and then i was just
like
oh because i mean sometimes people oh
the reason why i ask is because
in the past when we had a different show
with a different intro
people were like we don't like that
intro let's just not do that
and then so we stopped doing it for one
i don't even remember what that was a
different show
with a different engine oh come on don't
play keep away i'm playing people
everyone is now commenting
over there oh and then we're keeping
away from you keep the secret from them
yeah they don't need to know
they're already commenting it like the
comment section they already know yeah
i think you guys right now
it goes like this what's that from oh
that is a very accurate
yeah it was absolutely no one knows now
let's just say it out loud
it was a feel oh
i didn't know it opened that brutally
yes that's why we stopped
we stopped saying i never saw it i never
saw it that's really brutal wow
it was it was kind of brutal i'm glad
that that ended that's kind of what i
started thinking of right now with the
whatever we want and i'm like how do you
guys feel about it so that's right
it's not offensive like that one is uh
whatever we want totally offensive
well it's just it's like stabbing me
three times oh there we go
yeah it's just like take this yeah yeah
[ __ ] take it
wow it's been safe you should have seen
the animation with it then really
[Music]
oh yeah the animation boom that's the
fields
yeah but i mean i guess initially when
we started that intro was
fun like it was like oh this is fun like
we're getting into it but then after
like so
many episodes and it got so repetitive
plus that was for
every episode of that every single one
this is like
it's kind of an offshoot of another
thing so it's i actually
like the fact that we always had an
intro because i feel like
going to the video you kind of you have
something that leads you into the video
so that's the feels i would get it at
the time when you're filming me filming
20 of them back to back you're like okay
i'm tired of saying
yeah yeah i feel like from the viewers
perspective you're like okay i know what
i'm watching here
some of these things evolve right so i
watch this i watch a bunch of crypto
stuff everyone knows that but i watch
this guy named datadash and he's always
like
hello everybody smeared in here and i'm
like god damn dude you don't have to do
this
i know you did in your first video made
a thousand videos you think everyone
expects it
we hate it that's that's exactly what my
thought process was within the even
initially after i [ __ ] get it i'm
like
is it old now would you want to change
it should we change it oh no
i'm just i just wanted it yes we'll find
out now i want to talk
actually what do you guys think there
you go get rid of it get rid of this
whole show
so like you dump the whole show we're
like that's feedback
no you know what i do absolutely love
from you guys though is like you guys
will send me video clips
of like your your kids being like three
two one action that's really cute with
them side note i'm like why are you kids
watching this show
oh so sad some bad parenting
i wouldn't say that but i'm just like
well maybe they're just
too young they don't understand
especially when the videos used to start
off with in
[ __ ] up parenting news oh yeah
we used to say some [ __ ] up [ __ ] i'm
feeling i feel like i'm going down
memory lane right now
yeah and then like we would have to
think of like you know like
if they didn't submit it because then
the fans would submit it then we have to
think about like what are we going to
title this
i know but like some people had their
like favorite titles that they look
forward to like entitled
some criminals those are fun yeah
i remember you guys loved that you guys
your favorite you guys favorite every
single time was like
oh [ __ ] the parenting news yeah it's our
favorite and i'm like that's your
favorite
why which one was your favorite i don't
know
did i have one you're criticizing
favorites when you don't have a favorite
[Laughter]
i loved all of it they were all great
yeah wow
bringing up ask the feels old jk news
titles
can you believe it this thing has been
around for so long
yeah crazy wow sorry i'm like my mind
what about for the new people what's for
them what's for them well
currently we're we're getting meta in
this episode okay sir sir thank you
should go back and watch all those
videos just to catch up on everything
yeah this is the episode in those uh tv
shows where they like just do all the
whole bunch of flashbacks
[Laughter]
can we can we have the one where we talk
about like the sun asking the mom to go
and buy him a sandwich
and then like him killing both of his
parents eventually and like
joe puts his foot through the wall you
know you remember that like so clearly i
edited that one that story was
i mean like how can you not remember
when your boss kicks
the wall and i never even saw the actual
video for that oh
yeah i only heard about it many many
times but i had never
never seen it i just remember the act of
it i didn't remember what led up to it
but that's what that is what made the
dick shape on the wall yeah
i don't know i think that might have
been bart when we were playing chase
this is bart and that's part two it's
off camera but there's like a dick
shaped hole in a gigantic hole
a bad shape
boys will be boys you know i'm just over
here chuckling pretend like
pretending like i heard you but i really
didn't he said that shape hole
oh
and i still didn't fully understand
maybe i have some wax in my ears because
i heard
vag or vast vag it's a vast vag
that's kind baby
that's a wide vagina because it's a
circle it's pretty big
child birthing pretty much it's crowning
it's bigger than the dick on the wall oh
yeah
does anyone remember like did anyone in
like health class like see like a live
childbirth or whatever for like
like on screen and then no one warned
you about it oh damn
she was like whoa whoa i felt that way
when i watched knocked up for the first
time
oh that one scene where the [ __ ] baby
just comes right out i don't remember
how about seeing the little [ __ ]
swimming you're like
that's how many i kill when i jerk off
yeah you're just like i'm
a monster yeah
it's like this is genocide i'll do it
again
i'm still going to do it but i feel a
little bit weirder afterwards but [ __ ]
because they look like little tadpoles
and i always i had frogs as a kid
oh you did i didn't know that yeah how
many frogs too many frogs i had
two frogs
did you drag off into a water tank so
you could take care of him oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that is disgusting you did it
you left him speechless you win
i love that i love that i absolutely
love that he's like what are you doing
making frogs
i think i'm making frogs
okay we know where he's going to school
wow now steve's gonna try to think about
it come back
no the worst thing is that when i had to
let my frogs go because we were moving
and they couldn't have survived the trip
i remember letting them go in the woods
like fairfax virginia
was it the right were they native
ecosystems
well i thought so because it looked like
nice because it looked like the inside
of the tank we have like a little sticky
little leaf on [ __ ] there's like bigger
ones out there yeah yeah and then i
remember going to my friend
bj's house afterward his name was bj
which is hilarious
but i didn't know why later until much
later and then
um his dad was like you let your frog go
in the woods gonna die like immediately
and i was like
[Music]
[Laughter]
you like let it go you like let it go
and then you just hear
gosh i mean exactly dude well not to
mention it drops like 40 degrees at
night or whatever so
oh and they could have not acclimated
huh they needed warmth
i don't know like did you have a heat
lamp on them i don't know
they just became frogs i was a kid dude
does a kid ever actually
fully take care of something your mom
came in and that's why my mom got rid of
my turtles
exactly yeah i had turtles did she
release them into the wild yeah
you know what the desert and just like
no she released them into like the the
park
the little park pond oh oh okay yeah
dude i think my mom should have taken
care of my pets because i accidentally
killed a lizard and a hamster
how did you kill the hamster i killed a
hamster honestly i can't remember
if it was a hamster or if i killed both
lizards
but the point is i remember killing one
by accident and i think i
told this story but i was cleaning the
tank thing and then i didn't know where
to put the animal because i can't
remember if it was a lizard or a hammer
but there was two of them i do remember
that there were two
and and then like i put them under a cup
for some reason
so they wouldn't get away yeah but like
that doesn't it's not a good idea either
but anyway like and then as i was trying
to put them down
like it kind of got half out and then
like i panicked
but he wanted to leave and i
accidentally like
whoa and i think i just i think i just
did it to one because i don't think i
would have done it
traumatized i was like oh my god i
killed my bet
[ __ ] metal
i had two hamsters and
one ate the other oh my god because they
needed they needed to survive
you didn't feed them
[Laughter]
you forget as a kid you forget forget
key things
sometimes you're like no i fed that guy
yeah oh and then like
oh no one ate the other i wonder what
happened like what did that look like
like what happened
neatly stacked bones wait wait wait for
real clean
at least stacked bones did you leave
them alone
i forgot i had hamsters you forgot oh
they're gonna take the water to clean
though
is there any fur left not not one shred
of fur
where was the where was the hamster like
terrarium thing that you like kept it in
like the cage
yeah in your bedroom what was it like
where did you where did you put that
like cage
of like hamsters that you just forgot
about it yeah i mean uh it was in the
middle of my room for sure it was a
place i definitely should have seen a
lot
yeah i'll never i'll never get over the
bones
you know what would be really funny if
your parents were like you'd be you'd be
really great
if we took out one of the hamsters and
we put in these chicken bones in there
oh that would be fantastic it'd be so
funny when steve comes home
to this day i honestly think that
actually what happened was some kind of
act of aggression
oh between them two because we had this
like feeder thing
that like was actually stocked up yeah
but it's way more fun to tell the first
part
oh yeah true damn so we eat them he was
so
angry he ate them to the bone oh he
didn't just kill him is that common
amongst hamsters you think are they
cannibals i've never heard of that no
well they were not
regular hamsters they were albino
hamsters they had like red eyes and
they're all white
how'd you get the scariest looking
hamster
they were mean as [ __ ] and i remember my
mom told me she's like steven
petco's out of regular hamsters but they
have albino hamsters and
this is a life lesson for me like on the
day of my birthday i just wanted to get
hamsters right
and then she's like well you can wait
and get the hamsters that you want or
you can have your gratification today
and i was like i want it today
and then i got hamsters that as soon as
i took them home and put them in the
cage they bit me
so hard that he was hanging from my
finger as they put them in the cage and
it was all downhill from there
nice they were aggressive as [ __ ] this
is cute as [ __ ] too though it does look
like a
like mice yeah red eyes look like mouse
[ __ ] right there dude me
[ __ ] yeah i like to eat each
other
i never like wanted to take care of a
hamster because i went to like a pet
store with my mom and we were just like
looking around and then
i know that you probably weren't
supposed to do this but i was a kid and
i was dumb and then i was like i want to
pet the hamster so i put my finger
like in the cage and they bit me and
then i started bleeding and i was like
and then she like looked she's like oh
you got bills
couldn't talk and then so she like put
like a napkin around and she just
continued walking around the store
because i think she was like looking for
fish
or whatever mommy comfort me it's like
wait fish for what reason
uh fish tank okay dinner
it really was honestly because i'm like
i wouldn't be surprised
my grandma did that with turtles there
was no fish at a grocery store
she prepared turtles turtles from the
pet store and ate them no not from the
pet store but like from like 99 ranch
like way back in the day
they were meant to be eaten i know but
like but like when my grandma bought
them i honestly thought it's like cool
we got new pets and
she put him in like in this big bucket
and i was like wow hi guys welcome to
the family
oh you said welcome to the bag and i was
like hey guys
and then they handed you a knife and
they were like julia do the honors
no and then i think i went to school and
then i came back and then
um my mom was like oh here i have some
soup and i was like oh okay
so i drink some soup and i was like wow
this thing is pretty good and then as i
like scooped another one with like my
soup spoon like i saw like
one of the like the flippers oh my god
what is this and they're like
oh it's turtle stupid i was like
i'm a monster and then i was like
where did we get these turtles it was
like you know the ones we bought
yesterday and i was like
what you don't remember the ones that
you named last night i never knew
i'm so excited oh you said welcome to
the family i know i thought it was
bad but i'd never date them oh man
imagine you did though would you have
been like
charlie i know that's traumatizing i was
so tired
i couldn't drink the rest of the soup
that's fair yeah [ __ ] turtle drinker
turtle drinker no man my my grandpa used
to
raise rabbits for
like food yeah and pets i guess i don't
know i don't know the point is he had a
[ __ ] ton of
rabbits and he would sell them and he
would also cook them and one time
um like he i was around and he just got
a rabbit and he was about to do it
now i can't [ __ ] my memory's [ __ ] up
now but i can't remember if i saw the
killing or if i
didn't now but the point is they ended
up making that food later and i was like
i'm not touching it
at all like i just reminds you of when
we were
at long beach at the time uh they would
have the
like pita come out and it'd be like hey
uh watch this video of animals being
slaughtered and we'll give you a dollar
and uh oh man what yes
yeah students to watch it because no one
wants to watch that right and they're
like hey watch
this terrible video like farming for a
dollar like five people give you a
dollar
and i like sweet so we did that and then
we went and used that dollar and bought
some chicken nuggets
nice capitalism
pita a whole bunch of displays and then
like be amazed yeah just like yeah yeah
i never went in but i remember with my
carl's jr like mr big and cheeseburger
walking by me like
wow that's wild man hey can you believe
how they make these things now we know
yeah it's a two for six deal i got
another one if
but i mean i already knew how it went
down
yeah seeing animals die like being
slaughtered don't doesn't really faze me
i've actually seen
pigs being slaughtered in front of me
like i still don't
like the noise you hear you see the
struggle and everything
yeah i've seen in hawaii like i was at a
wedding and like
his family they they were butchers and
so they decided to
butcher some pigs in their backyard yeah
and they i guess they knew how to do it
officially they like found it
yeah and they like slipped the jugular
all that stuff and then like
and it's just but you see you see it all
happened in front of you and
maybe i was shook for like 10 minutes
and then next thing you know i'm like oh
is that the barbecue yeah well then you
smelled and you're like
you're like i was digging guys yeah i
don't know
yeah i still don't like it so i try to
cut back on meat but
i don't know steaks you know pig for me
is tough because they're so smart
apparently
very small but they're so goddamn
delicious you've seen videos of like
baby cows
oh i haven't yeah it's like people
adopting cows and [ __ ]
oh adopting oh really yeah just play it
just plays around with their dogs and
stuff and thanks
too yeah i know a friend's fostering a
pig
i don't want to foster a pig but i also
want to cook bacon sometimes yeah
and it would feel weird do you think
it's [ __ ] up too i think it's [ __ ]
up do you think it's [ __ ] up to feed
a pig baby yeah absolutely yeah do you
also think it's kind of funny too
it's kind of hard absolutely good good
good we can all agree duality of man
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you